now Justin Bieber is appearing all week
on The Late Late Show and last night he
headed to a dance studio
yeah after Bieber recently criticized
James Corden's dance moves the two
decided to work with young children to
learn new choreography
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I need to cool down I need to cool down
he brush deep breath deep breath just
take some deep breaths okay you got
[Music]
um this is amazing
Kristen saying I'm loving this Bieber
and we've talked about this on the show
I'm loving this beaver - he just is fine
he's making fun of himself I feel like
we're seeing more of his personality
than ever before we all know he went
through it's just like young stars do as
we can talk another jerk for a long time
yeah just saying you know it was a total
trick for a long time and then he went
through some really awful terrible
things and he had this whole he came to
it man and you guys at any child star
and this is the same thing we were
talking about milliwatt
Brown that machine has a thing a way of
destroying people and you know Bieber
was close yeah you know he was close and
now he's come out the other side these
two clips of him on James Corden is the
most endearing Justin Bieber I've seen
in years I know and I really really hope
that this continues facing love I love
this yeah like honestly everybody on
here is just saying great dance moves so
much fun love him this was cute he's
amazing so yeah and Kristen saying he's
grown now he's getting it together very
nice and he's good with kids too right
Lee yeah that's crazy